oh Jesus Oh proud to be in a mirror here
[Music]
hey what's going on and happy fourth of
July everybody for first we feast I'm
Sean Evans and you're watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings
and today we're joined by Adam Devine
he's an actor comedian and producer you
know him from workaholics on Comedy
Central one of the funniest shows ever
as well as his breakout role as bumper
in the pitch-perfect franchise he also
has a brand-new Netflix special called
best time of our lives and it's about
now Adam welcome to tango hey thanks I'm
a very very very very nervous to be here
that's normal that's normal
are you a spicy food guy do you crank
your wings oh I do I got a crank a wing
you have to crank your wings guys and I
wouldn't call myself a spicy food dude
but I do like I don't dislike spicy
[Music]
this is a classic piece of cake it's
bitter heart I contaminated every other
winger
Lucar
as we mentioned in your intro you have a
Netflix special that's streaming now but
I'm curious when you first moved from
Nebraska to California to chase that
dream what level of success seemed
realistic to you like what would be your
minimum accomplishment for you to feel
like well wow I made it that's cool I
don't know if I've ever answered that
question I feel like I had like
delusions of grandeur I'm like if I'm
not at a Will Smith level of Fame in
three years I'll husk corn for the rest
of my life and I just started to chip
away at it and I realized like you can
just sort of mini climb your way up then
I was like oh if I could just like do
comedy clubs and be a headliner and like
be a guy that is the guy for the weekend
I would probably be happy with that and
then comedy it's so competitive you know
there's so much focus on like who has a
special coming out or who's pilot got
picked up but I know that is a very
positive experience for you going to USO
shows and performing in Afghanistan in
Iraq did that shift your perspective on
what the meaning of your art could be
what's cool is like I run into people's
like family members all the time that
are like my brother-in-law saw you in
Afghanistan and that's pretty cool too
yeah this is a cutie with a booty what
if the bomb doesn't even affect me and
I'm just like oh I could eat these all
day has that ever happened I think we'd
have to just shut this head and study he
beat the sauce so they say that you
should write what you know when
workaholics is really an example of art
imitating life from you guys being
real-life friends before the show to
actually living in the house that was
featured and even your experience as a
telemarketer long before you played one
on TV
yeah is that really the soul-crushing
job that it seems to be on paper man
that job sucked what sucked about it I
like did like years of telemarketing
like as soon as I figured out that like
I had the gift of gab I was uh I was
like 15 or 16 and Omaha's like the
telemarketing capital of the world
because we could call all over the place
we're in the dead center so like there's
just call centers everywhere do you
remember any of the calls of any of them
stuck with you like I
like Ronald Reagan died and like the one
got like multiple people that day were
like how dare you want a day of mourning
and I'm like I didn't even like that guy
you know but you know all right Pete um
everyone wants to a while a guy like the
main trick that were played on use this
on a telemarketer they'd go oh yeah that
sounds interesting let's go get my
credit card and then they come back with
a blow one and this would happen like a
few times a week or someone you got blow
Lord yeah and your headset just falls
off and you'd look around the call
center all the time you can see people
and rip their headset off I like that
one klonda you're in - yeah okay I took
home a bottle of this well that's
convenient cuz I think we got one for
you oh so naturally we have to take a
wing to discuss workaholics one of the
funniest shows on TV for five plus years
nearly a hundred episodes he had so many
illustrious guests from rebel Wilson to
Jack Black to Ben Stiller can you reveal
a celebrity cameo that got away woody
harrelson like he was like a big fan and
he like reached out to me he actually
called me one morning I like 5:30 in the
morning and he was just like hey man I'm
a big fan I'm sorry I got your number
from Elizabeth Banks and I'm like
awesome and he's like I love workaholic
so you know if it makes sense I'd love
to come on the show too like I will I
will make this happen and so like it was
my main goal to like get him on the show
and we tried everything he didn't like
any of them he was like such a big fan
but as soon as we start to pitch him
ideas he's like mm-hmm
no no way besides take it sleazy what is
the adam demamp catchphrase that drunken
fans scream at you most in the wild ah
tight butthole I get I get a tight
butthole screamed at me I mean I talked
a little bit about my special Adam
Devine's best time of our lives
streaming now on netflix it's weird when
you're with people that maybe aren't as
well-versed with the show and you just
see like a stranger screaming about my
butthole size and then I don't correct
them I'm like that's right you know it
is keep it right keep it tight and
they're like they're like how does he I
want to ask Hollywood's a weird place
you know and then of course he not only
starred in the show but you're also a
creator showrunner
can you give us some of your favorite
Easter eggs that you guys have hidden in
the show over the years the whole like
show was an easter egg like a lot of
people don't know that we lived in that
house yeah like that was our house so
all of season one we were living there
so like like grips were like running
cables and setting up lights in my
bedroom as I'm like waking up being our
usual time for work and then I'd walk
out like my boxer shorts to like gate
craft services in the morning then does
word get out once workaholics blows up
like would you have people just showing
up at your house yeah liquid hands yeah
we'd have people like coming over and
like wanting to smoke weed on the roof
which we would do sometimes like
sometimes we'd climb on the roof with a
stranger but then you get on roofs too
many times with strangers and you're
like this is this is weird no like is
this how I die like some deranged fan is
like I could just push him off so we
then kind of stopped climbing on the
roof
[Music]
this is lucky dog I'm getting shaky come
on okay lucky dog I'll taste you so it's
our fourth of July special yeah yeah you
look like a guy who's into pyrotechnics
when's the last time you blasted off
some fireworks
Shawn has been too long
me too and that's why someone give me an
artillery shell let's bust it off right
here um but I grew up in the Midwest and
we would always go down to Missouri my
dad was a little bit of a pyrotechnic so
we'd always buy like hundreds of dollars
where the fireworks I'm like seven or
eight and my dad gave me like a gross of
bottle rockets I guess too young to give
your kid explosive flying expenses and I
remember I stuck one in a tree and I lit
it like this cuz I'm an idiot and I
light it and I couldn't see like that it
was lit because I'm seeing him front
right like a total like a seven year old
and I just got la gears thumb light up
snakes and it's shot and punctured a
hole in my shoe because I don't like
this and it popped my shoe out and I
just got in those shoes earlier that day
my mom was so bummed
[Music]
okay oh oh oh this one's a little juicy
[Music]
all right yeah this is a wicked fire
starter here this one I'm gonna pick up
the pace who's saying that wicked fire
starter prodigy
all right p.m. no fire twisted
firestarter man sounds good that won't
hit me right at the right age your mic
is all right Adam we have a recurring
segment on our show called explain that
Graham we're doing deep Evan I guess
Instagram pull interesting pictures that
need more context so I'll bust out the
laptop I'll show you the pictures you
just tell me the bigger stories that
sound good yeah man
what milk you go with I always go with
whatever the guest goes with oh really
and then that is like a wide range you
know yeah wid Kumail Nanjiani in here
last week you wanted VAT free chocolate
milk so Rilke so I drink that free
chocolate comedies in the specifics did
you have a most harrowing experience
swimming alongside sharks with Rob
Riggle oh dude I just like did Shark
Week last week I was in the Bahamas
that's why I've got this luscious tan
and just last night a woman was eaten
alive yeah look right where we were I
wasn't scared at all and now afterwards
I'm like sure I've been terrified
I like wasn't scared cuz it's like Shark
Week and no one's ever gettin no ones
have been bit right short week ever as
far as we know yes far as they've told
us and uh and so I'm like I'm fine but
we're done there there's tiger sharks
bit like a reef shark like all these
different sharks and they're just like
and I was like if it's like a fun zone
so um no I wasn't scared at all
I believe I should have been yeah what
did it mean to you to be inducted in the
Orange Coast College Hall of Fame I mean
they told me not to say this but you
know what are they gonna take down my
plaque I didn't even graduate right from
the community cop I dropped out of
Community College couple credits yeah
and then they invited me into the
inducted is the word say I didn't
graduate I don't know my vocabulary they
took me into the Hall of Fame at me and
Blake's Community College but it was it
was awesome is so cool that they did
that I don't know if I would have any
career at all if I didn't go there
because I met Blake and I met Kyle who
is our director Kyle new chick I met
them like day one of the improv class
they were just as driven as I was to
like just go deep into comedy without
the three of us made and I don't know if
I would even have a career so it means a
lot that they they came as chine and
then speaking of going deep oh look at
those two young bucks it's for a myspace
TV show yeah I remember this I do I was
paid like $300 and had to live in Vegas
for like a month I lost so much money
shooting that show we it was called
special delivery and it was like a
hidden-camera show
where like delivery guys would come over
and then we would act like we're in a
cult and he's our cult leader and one
time actually we were doing that and
we're like acting like this guy's a cult
leader and he's like this makes sense
and this like a real delivery guy and
he's like I've seen the devil he's
talked to me he told me if I ever meet a
woman named Sharon that I must end her
life
and we're like huh and he's like I'm
like have you met her yet and he's a
good not yet but I'm always looking and
so we have to like call the cops on this
cuz we're like he's gonna murder the
first Sharon that he meets so that was
that was that time in my life well
that's why you play explain that Graham
that concludes that segment all right
into the back half Enon Hellfire Detroit
this one seems chill
[Music]
use the classic one bites it down on
that one I'm following your lead Ron I'm
following your now off on yours
all right no cut
what's wrong what your follow my lead
so as legend goes your wildly unprepared
for your pitch perfect audition as I
understand it you thought that it was a
baseball movie at first and were taken
off-guard when they asked if you've
prepared a song yeah
can you pull back the curtain on that
experience because do you hear you
described that it gives me secondhand
anxiety yeah like um um just kidding I
feel so good yeah so yeah so uh pitch
perfect singing song so the audition
process
it's called pitch perfect and I was
working on workaholics at the time and I
was doing everything I was writing and
producing it starting in it and so like
I was like I don't have time for these
other auditions I got my show I must
prepare for this and then they're like
you have to go audition they really like
you for this movie and I'm like pitch
perfect baseball movie got it so like I
go I think it's a baseball movie I'm
like stretching in the parking lot I'm
like rubbing dirt on myself and then I
see all these hiked hot-ass dudes
because Hollywood is just like the hot
version of you is everywhere like
they're obviously going for like a look
and then you get there and there's just
all these like honky-ass like dudes or
like you know and they're all like
singing and I'm like good luck singing
in the baseball movie [ __ ] you know so
I get in there and then I'm like looking
at the sides and I'm like oh this isn't
baseball at all this is singing and I go
and I do the audition it goes pretty
well and then they're like what song did
you prepare like I didn't prepare a song
and they're like it was just something
from the radio so I legit sang bouncing
mother [ __ ] hand my time which was a
hit and they were like definitely don't
sing that song and then they're like
sing another song so the from your
childhood and I
whatever happened to predictability the
milkman the paper boy the evening TV
which is the full house theme song and
they were like you got it
like that's exactly what we were looking
for and this one has a very cool name of
Trinidad scorpion I was gone I was gone
there's a while ago I was shooting
somewhere and I'm in my shower I just
got home from from shooting I'd be gone
for like three or four months and I get
home and I'm in my shower and I look
down there's a scorpion in my shower
damn like right in my shower Maya that's
his shower like I just reacted with my
Old Spice body wash yeah yeah
sport no big deal and I'm just like
smile like spiked it right direct hit
man that could have gone real sideways
cuz I was being the aggressor but
sometimes that's what you got to do in
life you just got to go for it right
Shawn especially you know what I used to
I live in New York and I still like when
the summer comes you know sometimes
there's like some crazy big bugs in New
York
yep and one time I walked in the shower
and there was just some big thing that
was like this big and I that's too big
for take like multiple shampoo swings at
it and I felt like I'm murdered like it
felt like a murder
yeah nice dude
so I know that you're a journey into
Comedy Central it wasn't easy and that
you went through multiple iterations
before workaholics took on its form but
can you tell the people about the
instruments of destruction oh my god
what Sean where do you even find that
info dang deep cuts um of the
instruments of the scripts destruction
was me and Blake's sketch group prior to
mail order mail order comedy and
workaholics and we just had the most
bizarre sketches imaginable there was
like I was a senior in high school and
then we plant people all over the crowd
and and it was me like delivering a
speech and I go like hey this one's for
all the seniors out there you know who
you are and then I'd start to play
Everclear as Santa Monica I was like
changing June June June June and then
people would like start to boo me and I
and that was the level of comedy we were
working with but do you ever look back
on some of that old stuff and egg that
was our best work absolutely not no
we've gotten much much better than that
how are your lips feeling they are
numbing a little bit you know I got kind
of an icy hot feeling yeah yeah I feel
like I'm gripping on this side so like
this side of my mouth is fine and this
side is a little rough
hey cheer Shawn which was this serious
bomb beyond insanity and that I think I
said it before we don't need to go
beyond you know I stayed on this side of
insanity
[Music]
okay Sean I see you
beyond insanity yeah right
[ __ ] don't faze me
[Music]
easy too easy man that's too easy dude
too easy man too easy
so as someone who eats wings on the
internet for a living
yeah I'm very familiar in how parents my
job thank you and you too you know
because on paper there's a lot of stuff
for you that could be potentially
embarrassing
what's a project that you've done that
you're surprised that your mom really
liked um well Shawn game over man I felt
when my dick was out for about three and
a half minutes in that movie and I think
you might have seen my butthole and I
was surprised at how supportive she was
about that does your dad still roast you
for basic Hollywood stuff like wearing
makeup on set yeah he doesn't he still
can't get on board with that when I did
the intern Robert De Niro's anyway is
there another napkin thank you
we're quick on it yeah and my dad was
like I bet he doesn't wear makeup and
I'm like I've seen it he wears the
makeup all actors have to wear the
makeup and he still well he's still not
buying it did your dad hang up on Joe
Biden one time yeah dude I was up I was
doing this video with my boy Joey bods
what's up I'm like hey would you mind
calling that
I'd love to I don't like hey Dad I got
someone on the line for you and I hand
him the phone and he's like hi Dennis
this is Vice President Joe Biden and um
and my dad's like Yeah right
and hung up on him he knew I was going
the White House to meet Joe Biden and
I'm like what are you doing
he goes oh I thought it was one of your
Hollywood friends doing a Joe Biden
impression what oh man what did you do
to me John all right so this next one oh
my god Sean there's so much look at all
that snot man whoa oh Jesus Oh
[Music]
now to be in a mirror here alright which
one is this
we have the chocolate plague from pucker
bot
[Music]
I feel like that's the Steve Harvey
impression you ever watch family feud
when does someone say it was like we
just need a little nibble this one we
don't need yeah I went a little
overboard on that the bomb
I think the bravado yeah uh-huh mmm yum
yum yum yum yum mmm you gotta check out
the puck about stuff guys if you want to
chill afternoon it just happens of wings
but check out the amazing flavors from
pucker but so know that you're a
Nebraska boy at heart that you've been
chugging the big red kool-aid since the
days of Tommy Frazier and even last year
the mayor of Omaha declared November
10th Adam Devine day that has burned
always that's true
is it true that the first time that you
ever got buzzed was celebrating a corn
Husker national championship yeah yeah
so that is true I was like 11 or 12 and
I mean we start young in the Midwest and
we like they just won the national
championship and my parents took us like
downtown to like see the mayhem of
people like just celebrating and jumping
around and like pure just drinking all
over the place me and my buddy we're
just excuse me yeah we were feeling it
or at least that's we're a ton or so
whoa oh man I'm so messed up right now
Omaha Steaks overrated or underrated the
right amount of rated um they are
absolutely delicious the best cuts of
meat you could buy over the phone the
marbling just fantastic are they a
little pricey they are but the thing is
you could talk them down
they'll call they'll hit you with the
prize and you'll say no no no no no no
no no I know you got a sheet right there
give me that lowest price and then
they'll give it to you Nick oh no no no
no no no no no lower that mug and then
they will all right Adam
been in it been in it
[Music]
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's a tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last wing
smart you don't have to if you don't
want to Sean come on now look who you're
talking to
[Music]
okay let's Cheers this last one Cheers
[Applause]
[Music]
we get it all right Adam it's the fourth
of July and here we are at the end and
sure maybe you're not a decorated marine
or World War two veteran but you are a
living breathing example of the American
dream and he did sing the national
anthem that one time at a Dodgers game I
did so now on the off chance that there
are people watching us on the Internet
and not funneling beers on a boat or
lighting off m-80s can you hit it out
people with an Independence Day message
if you were to channel Randy Savage what
would be your inspirational July 4th
message to the people oh yeah to my boys
and girls out there in the great land of
America it's time to sit down that beer
and pick up your hand in salute the flag
then quickly put it back down and drink
that beer cuz what's most important in
the land of the free and the home of the
brave then drinkin beers
chugging brews with your boys and girls
get out there have fun be safe and
salute to the rocket men and women of
god Bless America and God bless you Adam
look at you 10 chicken wings up 10
chicken wings down now we're just gonna
roll out the red carpet for you Adam
this camera this camera this camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life hey what's up guys it's
Adam Devine I have my own Netflix
special streaming out on the vines best
time of our lives streaming now on
netflix check it our oats
[Music]
good job Adam good job
cool thanks man yeah that's how I'm
doing spirits you have a good time
holy [ __ ] dude I mean no wonder this
shows a hit I mean haylage it was crying
oh that looks fun he's Rocket Man Rocket
Man knows that it stops
about halfway hey what's going on hot
ones fans this is Sean Evans checking in
from the Museum of curiosities with a
very exciting sauce update if you have
not subscribed to the hot ones monthly
subscription box July it's the month to
do it why well first off limited-edition
sticker but second because this box is
going to have three hot sauces that have
never before been tasted never been
released never before seen until this
month they're all made by hot sauce
makers that have previously been
featured on hot ones that's right three
bottles of hot sauce no one's ever seen
before no one's ever tasted before no
one's ever touched until you reach into
that box and pull it out and put it on
your Caesar chicken wrap for the very
first time that's July subscription box
three bottles thirty bucks plus a
limited edition sticker who's looking
out for you us